cette année il n'y aura pas de vente de
muguet sur la voie publique mais les
fleuristes pourront néanmoins vendre les
clochettes du mois de mai devant leur
magasin au supermarché à guyancourt
quelques bras ont été installés à
l'entrée pour les intéressés avec tout
ce qui se passe là heureusement mois par
pedro ce jeu pour faire part en acheter
c'est des choses qu'on y pense quand
même
après voilà tout dépend de ce qui se
passe et tout ce qui est en ce moment ça
sent bon bah c'est vrai que souvent
comment on voit du monde ça fait plaisir
d'offrir donc oil sommes cette fois ça
risque de pas être pour offrir ça arrive
d'être pour soi commandez avant le
confinement
le co gérant du magasin installé son
stand de muguet ne sachant pas si les
clients ils trouveront un quelconque
engouement un supermarché on doit se
on se doit de proposer tout donc le
muguet fait partie des incontournables
en magasin l'idée c'est pas d'en faire
une quantité absolue mais c'est que les
gens on trouve tout ce qu'il faut dans
notre magasin comme et du textile et
caetera et caetera haut
o la fête des morts on vend du
chrysanthème on essaye d'être de tenir
la saison et les grandes fêtes c'est une
vente traditionnels pour le parti
communiste français qui chaque année
pour le 1er mai près par les brins de
muguet symbolisant la lutte des
travailleurs
aucune commande n'a été fait pour
respecter les consignes du confinement
néanmoins une vente sera bien organisé
mais pour recevoir du muguet virtuel
qu'on a organisé une man une vente de
muguet virtuel on a un visuel qui va
être adressée avec des courriels des
relances téléphoniques auprès de nos
camarades auprès de nos sympathisants
auprès des gens qui sont proches de nous
cette vente du muguet nous amener à
engager des frais importants parce que
déjà le média faut l'acheter donc ça on
ne leur a pas donc c'est à la fin qu'on
verra si on a eu moins de recettes ce
que que l'année passée qui on en a eu
pratiquement autant ou si on en a
davantage
il faudra attendre pour savoir si cette
année les bénéfices de la vente du
muguet virtuel ont été plus efficace que
la vente habituels